Jack besobic leaked the script his
entire script in the middle of his
speech so we're watching we've got 40
some odd thousand live viewers at the
time and I'm reading his words before he
even says them which I I get it they
have speech writers but it really did
make it feel so much more plastic like
someone wrote this forum and he was just
saying whatever it it didn't feel real
it felt to me like he was saying a bunch
of bad things were happening yes yes he
was police brutality killed this person
you know he didn't mention people are
smuggling eggs over the Mexican border
but he said a lot of don't worry we will
do things in the future his party has
been in power uh for the past two years
and they've done nothing but destroy our
country and make it worse and increase
inflation and and open our borders uh so
why didn't they do it then you know
we're battling this in committee right
now on natural resources and oversight
Democrats are saying uh you know we want
to work to do this we want to work to
secure the border and have immigration
reform well why didn't you do any of it
in the last two two years you had every
ability to pass whatever you wanted and
you didn't and Tim I kind of wish I
would have had his script because Matt
Gates and I were sitting together on the
house floor and we were wishing that uh
Joe Biden would just turn around the
teleprompter so we could read it
ourselves because half the time we're
saying what did he just say yeah well we
think he's talking about big Tech I
don't know there was a crazy point where
he said you could see in the closed
caption he said if Republicans try to
raise the cost of prescription drugs I
will veto it but what he actually said
was if Republicans try to
Albedo it yeah and the Democrats all
stood up and started clapping for it and
I was like what did he just what are
they clapping for
can is it I don't Ian's trying so hard
to talk we'll see what y'all couldn't
see were the Applause lights flashing
yeah so
but let me let me ask you about uh uh
one of the most contentious moments he
said that Republicans want to do away
with Social Security Medicare Medicaid
and then immediately the Republicans
start booing and saying no I can say
from what I've seen from the speeches
and from the news reports that's not
true and um I can only assume he's lying
on purpose for political power right
because they saw how effective this was
when Paul Ryan uh started talking about
social security and Medicare and you
know he's pushing granny off a hill he's
going to kill Granny and they saw the
effectiveness in that and haven't
haven't stopped even in my first
election the Democrat that I was running
against was saying that I was going
against these things I was like this
hasn't been on any of my talking points
this isn't part of any of my contract
with Colorado that I've laid out and
what I plan to do when I get to
Washington DC and so they're just
starting this rhetoric all over again
because they want to scare people they
understand the power of fear and that's
how they govern and I I won't govern out
of fear I won't be governed by fear and
they see this as a powerful tool to just
scare people into to falling in line one
of the things that I've been talking
about for the past couple days
ago prices because I don't know if you
know if you follow I'm a big fan of
chickens because we have chicken sitting
we have chickens all over the place and
uh I it's somewhat of a joke when I talk
about hey everybody get out of the
Cities get some animals get chickens and
it's funny because it's meant to be
somewhat silly because I find chickens
to be entertaining but then we get this
egg crisis do you put a pants on them we
we have they have armor actually they
have the the big straps on their
shoulders because well it's because the
roosters can be a little rough you know
when they take what they want but uh but
no now we're dealing with it with an egg
and chicken shortage which has been
coming in and out actually and what I'm
hearing from a lot of the more liberal
people is that well no this is caused by
the avian flu which doesn't explain why
people are smuggling eggs from Mexico
into the United States right which is
more indicative of a policy problem
that's not being taken care of or fixed
so what was that are we getting
somewhere nope nope but but in that
regard I guess uh my question for you is
what do you think should be done right
now that would help lower the cost of
food maybe increase wages like what are
some economic ideas that you think the
Republicans could implement I mean
obviously we're working on the spending
there's been Reckless spending here in
Washington D.C
um you know and rightfully both parties
are are to cause or to blame for that
um but the past two years uh I it's just
been absolute out of control spending
whatever you want you get a stimulus
check and and we're we're increasing all
of all of these
um uh spending bills by trillions of
dollars we're given less than 24 hours
to actually read the bills before we
vote on them um so that's obviously a
big factor um so we're going to tackle
that debt ceiling debate um here in the
upcoming months but also American Energy
I mean let's get us energy independent
again Joe Biden surrendered that you
talk about surrender he surrendered our
American Energy on day one in his office
at the stroke of a pen and so let's
drill here responsibly let's have
American Energy uh and uh and and
produce that reliably and affordably for
Americans I mean those those two things
right there coupled together lower
inflation and uh and help Americans get
out of this mess Biden literally
campaigned on ending fossil fuels yes he
was on the debate stage saying that he
will work to end fossil fuels in this
country then he does the State of the
Union addresses not just this one but
the past one where he's talking about
how he's going to help but he's not now
in fact we just got uh new emails
released the Daily Mail reported this
Hunter Biden laptop emails showing that
Joe and Hunter were working on a deal to
sell natural gas from Louisiana to China
right now I think I I think it was after
he was vice president before he became
president but I mean it's clearly based
on what he said and what he's done as a
private business person in between his
his uh public office
it seems to be more interested in
selling off our energy and shutting it
down yes absolutely uh well I mean even
emptying our strategic petroleum uh
petroleum reserves that was in the name
of a midterm election uh this was for
emergencies and he did it uh to win
political points with voters uh but no
he's absolutely shutting down American
Energy and even in the State of the
Union last night uh Joe Biden's like hey
look I get it
oil we got at least a decade left of it
like what the entire Republican party is
uh erupted and and laughed her at him so
he did campaign on canceling uh fossil
fuels and he did it on day one on day
one
um there was all of these executive
orders that came out moratoriums on
leases on federal lands and ending
fracking in Colorado's Western Slope we
used to have 112 rigs drilling now we
have four our communities have been
regulated into poverty and it's really
unfortunate because we produce the
cleanest energy and Nobody Does it
Better Than American Energy producers
and he's shutting it all down you know
what I think is worrying with all of
this
Joe Biden can do all of these things he
can he can put a moratorium on uh oil
and gas leases on Federal Land he can
shut down Keystone Pipeline
regular people can't understand how that
leads to higher gas prices right because
it's a bit outside of the common
knowledge and I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to anybody who doesn't get
it but uh we've talked about on this
show when he shuts down Keystone we get
the talking points in the media that
this thing was never delivering oil in
the first place therefore it doesn't
matter on on this show we explain
speculation that if right now they're
telling you in the next five years we
will not be able to meet demand because
Transportation will be unavailable that
means Supply will be constrained this
causes people to speculate the prices
are going to go up which causes the
immediate effect of them buying as much
as possible which drives prices up yes
so it's all interconnected and I wish it
was much much simpler than this but I
can put it simply when you've got
California Oregon Washington saying
where to ban gas cars yet their agenda
is clearly aligned with shutting down
fossil fuels because they're concerned
about climate change right look fine I
mean if they're concerned about this
stuff I get it I think you know there's
pollution pollution bad and all this
stuff but this idea that we get from the
more extreme elements of this movement
notably Greta tunberg which is she
outright said we want to shut down
fossil fuels now we don't want to wait
like that would result in 60 million
dead around the world within like a day
or so absolutely you know fossil fuels
have lifted so many people out of
poverty uh and uh they do want it shut
down and even when California said you
know we're going to ban gas vehicles
well the very next week they said hey uh
please don't charge your electric
vehicles because our grid can't handle
it I mean that was the very next week
and so their policies do not work
they're they're not effective but they
are effective in their messaging and uh
and they're they're doing everything
that they can to to destroy it
um if they want to talk about climate
change well I I mean I have forestry
legislation
um that deals with that very issue and
look I'm not here to deny climate change
it's real happens four times every year
I'll go on the record and say it but if
carbon emissions if that's if that's
your problem well then let's manage our
forests because one catastrophic
Wildfire emits more carbon emissions in
a few short days than every vehicle in
my state of Colorado running 24 7 for an
entire year
nope nope
[Laughter]
can pull it out of the atmosphere which
we can and turn it into graphing and
re-industrialize our country I mean it's
it's waiting for us to take and it's
going to become competition for the
carbon in the air the Chinese CCP is
going to start attempting to strip it
out faster than we can so if we don't
work together hi everyone is it working
tell me good please you can hear me no I
don't
know it's just Proof of Life
well so you know look I I
like the I I I understand people are
concerned about carbon emissions and I
think there's like a rudimentary there's
there's something basic that people can
understand in the more people you have
the more energy you consume the more
waste products are produced the more
pollution you get and I think the
simplest the the best way it's been
explained by a lot of uh conservatives
is we must be good stewards of the Earth
right but I'm sorry as as much as you
know I'll I'll back up eyesore for
Greenpeace briefly I worked for an
organization called environment America
I actually went around telling people
like hey we got to be good stewards of
the earth we got to protect the forest
we got to clean this stuff up and then I
got really confused when I'd hear
stories about politicians buying
beachfront property while telling me
that they're going to be swept up in the
oceans and so my thought was either they
don't care about what happens to the
rest what what happens to this planet in
20 or 30 years if they're coming out and
saying we're gonna work these it's gonna
be wiped out in 20 years but then they
buy the property they clearly don't care
right or they're just lying right
no you're not
everybody can hear so do you want to
swap back Lauren and take this seat back
let's make sure you're early on first
what about carbon sequestration because
because darn it that was good stuff
no audio for me in so so we have we have
an audio meter it's showing like Ian
you're not coming in yeah so we can hear
you in the headphones but no one can
hear you on the show so I don't know um
you can maybe bring the bring the chair
over here and then I'll just swing the
mic around to you
you know
Brian says no yeah well maybe some
people are picking up the feedback from
the other mics yeah like you might be
able to hear something faint in the
background well I don't know see if I
don't know man look we threw this
together in a couple hours it is what it
is so let's just uh we'll just keep
talking I suppose you know I don't know
if anyone you pull want to pull up a
chair or something
okay Ian's gonna try and see what he can
figure out with this stuff but yeah so
look uh I grew up in the city I grew up
in Chicago I grew up surrounded by
liberals I grew up surrounded by
democrats and they and and it all makes
sense to me when you hear stories about
dead zones in uh in the Gulf of Mexico
where life can't exist when you hear
about the mercury levels in our fish I'm
like hey these things sound really
really bad I would like to uh have you
know ecological balance I'd like to
clean up pollution I don't like the idea
of big garbage dumps I'm concerned about
the pollution produced by big cities
and then I just don't trust them right
when you know Obama so we actually did
this we pulled up the I think it was
what is it the um NOAA or the uh what's
the ipcc the climate change panel we
looked at their projections for Obama's
property at Martha's Vineyard right it
will be underwater right so according to
their predictions yeah they're they're
and that that wasn't even their worst
case predictions there it was like
moderate predictions of sea level rise
puts half his property underwater in 10
or 20 years right and I'm just kind of
like well does he really care about this
because if he's what what he and all the
rest of them are saying is true does he
not care that he's spending 10 million
dollars on property they'll be worthless
soon right that's why I can't trust it
right absolutely uh you know I I was
wondering why AOC got so worked up over
ilhan Omar not being able to serve on on
a certain committee when the world's
gonna end in six years anyway yeah they
they tend to keep saying this and then
people just end up not wanting to
believe it which is on did you guys
figure it out
started popping on nope turned it off
and I'm still not working unplug it plug
it back in
no but uh but we can continue
so anyway
are you guys friends
I'll I'll relay that uh are you friends
no I pretty much have to take the stairs
now because I'm not allowed in elevators
with her wait what really yeah
well so let's actually yeah that's an
interesting question look I wanna uh
talk about the the the the Twitter stuff
too but let me let me ask you about just
the general feel in Congress what we see
with AOC especially today in the Twitter
hearings is outrage right over January 6
outrage over Republicans yes what's what
what's it like between you know the
freedom caucus or or just you personally
and Squad members
uh well I I mean I don't have a
relationship with them uh you know there
there were some things that obviously um
you know we we kind of sided with them
um on some of the issues when we were in
the minority because they were trying to
kick against their party and we were all
for that
um but uh I I don't have that
relationship and you know it's it's
really hard and um to to take anything
these guys say seriously because
everything out of their mouth starts
with Maga Republicans did this in
January 6 and insurrectionists and you
know all of this rhetoric instead of
actually just talking policy and talking
Solutions let's have a conversation they
were saying that today's Twitter file
hearings
um regarding the hunter Biden laptop
that was suppressed by Twitter by these
Twitter uh Executives uh that was a
waste of time and that we need to move
on how is defending free speech and
holding people to account a waste of
anyone's time would that we are the
oversight and accountability committee
we are there to have congressional
oversight we uh where we believe that
there was collusion between the federal
government and with Twitter with big
Tech and so we were having congressional
oversight into what actually happened
was there collusion with the federal
government and the and these companies
and and then I expect accountability to
come out of this as well thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time